president joe biden unveiled his
long-awaited 2 trillion dollar
infrastructure bill wednesday
the bill is a sweeping proposal to
revitalize american infrastructure
manufacturing and begin the transition
to clean energy
the bill includes 621 billion dollars
for transportation infrastructure like
roads and bridges
111 billion dollars for clean drinking
water and 100 billion dollars
respectively towards expanding broadband
and power infrastructure like the
electric grid there's also 213 billion
dollars for affordable and sustainable
housing
400 billion dollars for the care economy
and 100 billion dollars for workplace
development
the biden administration proposed paying
for the bill with new taxes and tax
increases on corporations including an
increase in the corporate tax rate from
to 28 a major hike but still seven
percentage points
less than the 35 percent corporate tax
rate under presidents obama
bush and clinton biden wants to
introduce a 15
minimum tax on book income for big
companies meaning that even if a company
takes a lot of credits and deductions
it would still have to pay taxes on at
least 15 of its earnings
that's intended to prevent the country's
largest corporations like amazon from
using those deductions and credits to
skirt paying taxes
according to an analysis by tax notes
chief economist martin sullivan
33 of the 100 largest u.s companies
might see larger tax bills because of
that 15 percent minimum tax
including giants like at t jp morgan
chase
and target biden also wants to enact tax
penalties designed to make manufacturing
abroad more expensive
this could include levying a 10
offshoring surtax on income from the
production of goods and services
produced overseas
but sold in the us by american
corporations
he also wants to couple this with a tax
credit for companies that
onshore or bring back jobs to the us
biden is expected to introduce the
second part of his american jobs plan in
april
that proposal will include provisions
related to health care and child care
you